when it comes to lifespan there really
are four big elephants in the room the
first is atherosclerosis just no matter
how you cut the data more people are
going to die from cardiovascular disease
than anything else cancer is number two
pretty much consistently in the same
boat then you get into neurodegenerative
diseases and a lot of this Roots back to
metabolic Health yeah I'm glad you
brought it up because I kind of got
distracted when you first asked me about
the four horsemen I forgot that one once
you have type 2 diabetes your risk of
those other diseases doubles
and the challenges you know in some ways
these are the hardest things to fix
because it comes down a lot to exercise
nutrition and sleep you have to manage
nutrient you have to be exercising I
mean there is simply no better Elixir
for metabolic Health fuel partitioning
glucose disposal than being active
and if your sleep is dysregulated it's
almost impossible to overcome it with
enough exercise and nutrition